on the inbounds falling and tip crap my  Turkish guns in ahead of Lilly lowered  into the paint turns swings it to Aminu  makes a tremendous catch back to  daybreak  [Applause]  from the outer limits reels in the three  Blazers lead at 110 109 five in one 10  seconds left in the overtime what a  scramble that was a tremendous catch by  Aminu who runs down a 50/50 ball look at  the turnover because of the hands to  ammo the deflection and this is this is  controlled chaos in an extent the Pacers  trying to rush and get his shot and dame  ends up with it in the corner what a  deflection from Oh  and in Dame saying I didn't forget about  all that nonsense that took place in the  first half green riding him to the  baseline got in the ear that's a great  place the play from Chima was in to get  that mob that thing down because it  didn't look good when it left his games  didn't Damian Lillard tonight 21 points  on three of eight shooting from three  this has been a sensational ball